okay perfect all right we're gonna get
started i'm shannon McWeeny i'm the
division head for bioinformatics and
computational biology also now known as
computational biomedicine and I'll talk
a little bit about that change in my
talk my work is I'm a methodologist and
so my research has really been focused
in a couple of areas I use the phrase on
this slide about solving research
bottlenecks and so the idea is that all
of the methodology work that we do is
problem driven and so a setting like Oh
H su which is a University Hospital is
ideal for this so we're really thinking
about what are the obstacles not just
for research but very importantly for
the clinicians and for our patients and
trying to improve outcomes and care a
lot of my work actually is focused
around what we call precision medicine
and this is thinking about how do we
identify the right drug and not just the
right drug for a patient or a group of
patients but the right dose the right
timing for that drug etc and so that's a
key component of my work that I do with
the OHS unite Cancer Institute which is
our Cancer Center here I like to give a
little bit of background about me and
I'm not going to read this slide but I'm
gonna mention a couple of things my
training was non-traditional and we have
a lot of people in the program that have
non-traditional training in fact I think
the more diverse your background is
sometimes the better off you are in
terms of your perspective so my PhD was
in statistical genetics which is exactly
like it sounds a very quantitative
rigorous assessment but very applied in
genetics so I worked on complex diseases
and then I went on and did a postdoc
which also was further training and
certification getting a master's in
computational biology and one of the
reasons for that is that I was
recognizing that the amount of data that
we were generating and analyzing was
growing vastly and I did not have the
skills computationally to handle it so
quantitatively and methodologically I
could think about the data and the
problems but I also needed that
computational training as well and I
would and I'll come back to this but I
think the idea that to really be
effective in this area you really are
looking at interdisciplinary training
hybrids right so my training reflects
genetics and biology it reflects
statistics and mathematics it reflects
computer science I would also argue
there's a lot of things around kind of
cognitive aspects and and I'll talk
about that again at the end as well just
in terms of how we think about making
data or knowledge accessible to other
people but I definitely think that in
terms of the best return on investment
all of my quantitative skills really
became this kind of arsenal or tools in
my tool kit that I've been able to use
for a variety of problems so when I
started I was working on complex
diseases in particular autoimmune
disorders like type 1 diabetes and that
gradually shifted to really now my focus
is on predominantly cancer but also
infectious disease where I do a lot of
work as I mentioned around thinking
about new therapies also drug
repurposing and prioritizing targets for
developing therapies so I like to use an
example that came from a lecture on our
talk that was given by Jim Gray who was
a scientist at Microsoft which kind of
really describes where we are right now
because a lot of people have
misconceptions about what are the real
challenges that we have in terms of
dealing with the vast amounts of data
that we're generating so Jim laid out
this idea of these paradigm shifts in
terms of the way that we think about the
world around us and very importantly the
way that we're attempting to process
that information and gain knowledge and
so the first paradigm shift was really
descriptive where we were largely going
around and cataloguing the world around
us just describing it very qualitative
we then went into the second paradigm
and this is theoretical or and now we
were able to abstract and think about
concepts that we could not see and
actually do much more complex
abstraction we just emerged from the
computational paradigm and so this is
where the misconception is we can handle
vast amounts of data in fact we have
approaches that will allow us to handle
data we can't even store so we can
develop very sophisticated data
structures very sophisticated algorithms
but what that has placed us in so that's
not the challenge it's places now in
this fourth paradigm which is around
exploration and so I use this term about
having data be accessible a lot of
people think that means open data can I
share data can i download it or touch it
that's not at all what I mean
I mean accessible in terms of knowledge
so you have very complex data structures
you have a ton of data that's coming at
people how do we make sure that
cognitively this is what the cognition
part comes in that they can actually
interpret that and get meaning from it
and make it actionable and that's
critical for medicine and that's really
why in terms of our focus especially
given the representation of being in a
university hospital we shifted from this
idea of kind of the traditional
computational biology which is often
much more focused in basic science to
computational biomedicine really
leveraging the environment around us and
our training reflects that as well
I would point out that this is also
where there's the greatest need so if
you're interested in things like
visualization etc this is this is
massive we're actually actively
recruiting people from other sectors not
science because it's so critical that we
can make it clear that this information
is accessible in the way that I just
described ironically and I didn't put it
my slide deck they just announced that
tableau had been acquired which is a
visualization and we're kind of
reporting software it was one of the
largest acquisitions ever for a
visualization based software and it
really again harken to this idea that a
lot of this is going to be around
context and interpretation that's really
what's going to be critical as we move
forward now we talk about all this vast
amounts of data and I always think it's
good to make this somewhat personal in
terms of the amount of data that you're
generating so this is a slide from some
collaborators at Intel and IBM and what
you're looking at is the various types
of data that we might generate and what
I want you to think about is that when
we think in a healthcare setting people
talk about clinical data and we always
imagine that to be vastly more than it
actually is it really is about 10% when
we think about determinants of health
right and it's actually the smallest of
all the data you're going to generate in
your overall lifetime then we think
about genomics and this is an area where
again because of sequencing the idea
that you can sequence your genome that
if you have a cancer for example we'd
sequence the tumor this is thought to be
a major piece of data it is larger than
the clinical data but it's still nowhere
close to the exogenous data so this is
your behavioral the socio-economic
environmental all the data that you're
just passively generating that we're now
starting to collect which actually is
critical when we think about a lot of
the and I'll show you an example there's
a lot of type of modeling and
understanding we really want to do
especially because the environmental
factors behavioral factors are so
critical in medicine that's the majority
of the data that you will generate and
that's the part that we're often
overlooking so Eric Schadt developed
this idea in this slide of the data
ecosystem this is a very common concept
but I really love his interpretation of
it in this image because he's pointing
out a lot of those exogenous passive
data types that you are generating so if
you're doing any kind of banking or
financial transactions traffic patterns
as we all know many of us use things
like Google Maps or Waze my iPhone at
anytime knows where I am where I've
parked my car I don't know if you've
seen that where it lets passively tell
you you just parked your car here
haven't asked it to do that
so obviously the cell phone in terms of
social media texts do anything that you
download we also have things like
security and automation air traffic
definitely when we think about
infectious disease and things like that
we definitely think about transit so
things like air traffic weather GPS all
of this data is being generated and
actually captured in some form that
could be leveraged and the reason that
we think this is important is because
when we think about what we're actually
focusing on in terms of your health so
we think about things like obesity
obesity is going to be so obesity is a
really great clinical trait to think
about in terms of studying because it is
a corner piece to many other diseases so
when you think about cardiovascular
disease patients often will also have
obesity right if we think about there's
a co-occurrence for example of obesity
and many addiction behaviors so it's
very hard to isolate some of these skin
effects they're actually connected and
what may be hard to see is that on this
we're actually looking at a graph it's
basically connecting a lot of these
different disease phenotypes together a
great example is type 2 diabetes which
we know has an environmental component
and obesity would obviously be a key
thing that we need to consider when
we're treating a patient with
type-2 diabetes so we think about all of
this but we need to think about not just
the interplay of the genetics and the
clinical data with respect to these
different diseases or phenotypes the
patient has but also thinking it in the
context of the environment and it's from
that that we really will get much better
models for predicting disease now that
use case that's often used for this that
is very common think about is as I
mentioned infectious disease or a
pandemic where you'll see people
modeling really thinking about
transmission but we're thinking about
this much more broadly just in terms of
understanding what were the things that
you were exposed to how do those
exposures actually change your
susceptibility to things and that may
not just be things like viruses or
pathogens but also if you've had a lot
of environmental exposures that may have
increased your risk for things like
cancer for example all of that are the
pieces of the puzzle that we need to
kind of put together so um one of the
things that is really important to me is
that I have what I call my internal
barometer in terms of why I get up in
the morning and do the work that I do
and this is an image that was taken with
the patient's permission and her
family's permission from a photography
24-hour photography basically
documentation of OHSU called one day at
OHSU and this is autumn who was one of
our patients at the time and was being
treated and the good news of course is
that this had a good ending in terms of
her outcome it was positive which is
great but when we think about a patient
like autumn there's a number of
questions that we want to ask and this
start to when their diet when they're
diagnosed we think about things like are
they going to respond to the standard of
care and for certain diseases especially
some of the ones that I work on the
answer is almost always no because we
have unless the patient has a very
favorable risk or outcome it's often the
case that that might fail them we want
to think about what the treatment plan
is that's best for them if the patient
does relapse then what's going to be our
next line of defense in terms of second
line therapies and this is critical to
us so we tend to think about this as
basically a life cycle in terms of how
we're thinking about monitoring and
following the patient and this goes
again relating back to that idea of
precision medicine what we want to be
able to do is improve that we want
be able to improve number one this
standard of care that's the ultimate
goal but because this is in a research
context right now what we're hoping to
do is understand what are the best lines
of therapy in terms of these second
lines of therapy after relapse or
recurrence to help our patients so what
happens is that when a patient comes in
remember we're talking with a different
data types that we collect we have the
clinical data which is in the electronic
health record that will include things
obviously like the symptoms vitals etc
but very importantly also family history
which could be really relevant and then
with diagnosis and this is part of a
research this model that I'm showing you
here as part of a research study that
has been actively ongoing for over five
years if not more at OHSU and other
sites to really under this is a cancer
story where when the patient is
consented and enrolled in the study
along with being you know receiving
their primary diagnosis and being cared
for we're doing a number of things in
the background with the patient's
consent to samples that they're
providing so basically a diagnostic or a
pretreatment sample and this is
important we're characterizing things
like when we think about genomic
sequencing so what mutations and a
cancer that they might have we're
characterizing what are the levels of
the gene expression that they might have
because that can actually help us in
terms of understanding what is
dysregulated or aberrant from the cancer
we're looking for things like
upregulation what might be targetable to
drugs and then we do a series of
functional assays in which we're
actually testing the patient's sample
with a large number of small molecules
so testing them with drugs to actually
try to predict how they might respond
now remember this is a clinical study
research study so the patient will go on
to standard of care and then especially
for some of the diseases I work on like
acute myeloid leukemia the patient
unfortunately has a high probability of
potentially relapsing and we're not
responding to the standard of care and
if that's the case then we would repeat
this cycle again and now we're in the
paradigm where they might be appropriate
for a clinical trial and we can begin to
think about this and we update all that
information and behind the scenes we're
modeling that to try and understand what
would be the right based on all the data
we've collected what do we think the
right potential targeted therapy or
comedy
therapy is for this patient and the goal
is that we can learn from this so that
when someone comes in we've either
updated the standard of care so we have
the best option for them from the
beginning or we're ready if the senate
of care does fail them with a therapy
that we know they have a much better
chance of responding to and this is work
that I think as I mentioned was done at
multiple sites 11 different academic
institutions were part of this
consortium
for this model for acute myeloid
leukemia which we call PETA AML and 11
different pharmaceutical companies as
well now there is a component I
mentioned to you that you know in this
case the bead AML model was a
collaboration we had 11 different sites
you know sharing data and and consenting
patients and collecting this information
and that resource went public in 2018 in
October of 2018 and it was made
immediately available to the research
community with the idea that we wanted
to be able to share this data but we
know that clinically we have a number of
things that are happening where the data
is often locked because of a number of
measures which are actually in principle
great to actually protect you know the
patient in terms of security etc privacy
very importantly but we have patients
that actually want their data shared and
so there's been a huge discussion
publicly around the patient's right of
access which is a legal thing that every
patient has and how can we actually
improve that so that if they want their
data shared a research study it's not
trapped in the initial hospital where
they had their care this slide is
actually from an opinion piece from
Laurie Buckland and she was a breast
cancer patient when she was diagnosed
that breast cancer had metastasized and
Ana metastasized to almost every one of
the major kind of common metastatic
sites that we think about so normally
the prognosis would actually be very
poor she went on to live another seven
or eight years beyond this and when she
finally was to coming to the disease she
wrote this opinion piece and what she
commented on is that every you know if
there's another patient like her in the
United States or in the world where they
have similar clinical characteristics
potentially even similar tumor types etc
her information about what happened
to her and her kind of journey
clinically what she responded to what
she didn't trying to understand what was
special about the ability for her to
have this you know longer-term survival
with very advanced metastatic disease
that could potentially help another
patient but it was basically gonna be
trapped in the electronic health record
and she brought up this idea that every
patient basically is a one-person
clinical trial and that if this data was
gonna die with her this would be
criminal and I think the mountian
message has really been heard loud and
clear and there's been a tremendous
amount of effort that even though this
data is now collected electronically we
still often have these barriers around
it being inaccessible and in this way I
am talking about actually the sharing
part the ability to touch it right so
there's two versions of accessible
there's the accessible in terms of
knowledge can I understand it
cognitively and there's the accessible
in terms of is it being shared and our
mission really is to work on both of
those kind of simultaneously this
hopefully should be the easier one
although this often ends up because of
as we talked about security and
compliance issues definitely there's a
cultural component to the hospitals as
well many hospitals see some of this
data as intellectual property so we
really need an education not only to
help our patients understand what their
rights are but also of the hospitals and
universities as well so as I mentioned
to you before we have all this data that
we're generating and especially in the
clinic so we have this idea of how we're
kind of reshaping medicine so I showed
you the research version in which we
were doing all of this genomic and
functional characterization but right
now at OHSU we routinely have in our
cancer care sequencing that is being
done of our patients often it's a
targeted panel but sequencing that's
being done where we can give information
about various mutations that they may
have that we can follow them
longitudinally and the reason this is
important is a patient starts treatment
and what we're trying to understand is
how much of the disease burden is left
or still present and we call this
minimal residual disease and so we can
monitor that's through the sequencing
it's a not perfect yet but it is
something that is actually very vital in
terms of thinking about care as well as
potentially
understanding what drugs they might
respond to now as we try to add
complexity to that data in terms of
either doing rather than just doing a
targeted panel of a set of genes doing
whole exome or whole genome sequencing
the amount of information that then has
to be analyzed and presented back is
challenging and we now have this
separation between the clinician and the
data in terms of these algorithms that
they are no longer transparent to them
the other challenge is that
bioinformatics is also kind of seen as a
rate limiting step so those are the kind
of things that we want to try and change
and there's a number of ways that we can
do that we've talked about the making
data accessible and the visualization
which is key cognitively but at going to
the point I just mentioned about this
kind of disconnect between the clinician
or the oncologist jux are going to be
making a decision to care for the
patient using all of their expertise and
needing to understand now this will say
recommendation or analysis summary that
came computationally we have to make
sure that that data is clear in terms of
being transparent them really
understanding how confident we are if
there's any uncertainty around it so
there's that education as well and then
finally we really need to think about
the human data interaction piece and
this dovetails really nicely back into
what I already mentioned to you about
the work that's been happening on really
empowering and engaging patients to
understand their role in their data and
so there's a number of concepts that
come up here one of the most important
ones is negotiability also agency we
want patients to feel like they have
autonomy when it comes to their data it
is their data so if they want to share
it with another institution even if it
was collected at one Hospital if they
want to consent to be in a study if they
want to stop participating in a study
all of those things are really critical
that we're actually providing that to
them and we think a lot about
human-computer interaction and we talked
a little bit about that in terms of the
visualization but that human data
interaction and really supporting that
is critical all of the heart of all
research is our patients especially
clinical research translational research
and so we need them to be active
partners with us and that's not always
the way that patients feel and always
the way it's presented to them and for
to happen they have to have autonomy in
terms of that partnership so that's a
major focus that's happening now not
just nationally but internationally as
well so I want to just talk a little bit
and then we can take some questions
about the program here so I mentioned to
you that we really try to leverage the
environment around us and that's really
where the computational biomedicine
component came from there's another
number of other areas that I'll mention
to you and some of them have that we
have them really kind of focused on
healthcare clinical and translational
research but they can be applied
anywhere so you see machine learning is
on that list and as you know in the news
right now machine learning is being
applied to everything but there have
been a number of very promising aspects
for machine learning in terms of things
like imaging and also some other key
clinical areas where this is really
being investigated text mining and
information retrieval this can apply to
any type of literature or text where
you're trying to to pull back actual
concepts especially if the data is
unstructured here we really focus on
things like the electronic health record
so a ton of data is captured when you
come into the hospital most of it those
often in the notes so free text and so
the idea that we can use computational
approaches to basically take that data
out extracted reason on it and help us
identify those key concepts is really
important I already mentioned my
background in statistical genetics
analytics is also another really
important one again it'll analytics and
data science is very broad covers many
areas here we're really focusing on this
in the context of healthcare analytics
we have a partnership with Kaiser in
which they teach a course every summer
they come in and we actually you know
you get to kind of shadow them in terms
of what is it really like to be doing
healthcare analytics in a system like
Kaiser and very importantly you go
through the entire lifecycle of what
that's like in terms of if we're
thinking about actually implementing a
new algorithm that would help in making
determinations so one of the examples
that we use is what's the readmission
risk if the patient comes in the
hospital needs to know depending on what
ending on my next step how high or how
likely is it they're going to be
and so how do you implement an algorithm
like that how do you evaluate it and
then how do you make the decision which
or the recommendation back to your
organization about what should be done
next and so those are all things that
you actually get to do with them and get
feedback from their team and their
experts so what happens in the program
in the first year in this summer there
is an online boot camp so they're in
data science and in bioinformatics and
computational biomedicine competition of
biology we often talk about a couple of
key programming languages one is Python
which you learn in the program and the
other is R which is a statistical
language which is actually also really
critical
there is a online boot camp for R if
you've never had any programming
experience there's also an online kind
of refresher course for Python and then
you formally take the full Python course
which is really focused on scientific
scripting in the fall you also do
research rotations you can start those
then and then you have kind of our core
coursework in the fall winter and spring
and it's actually fairly prescribed
because there's so much material that we
need to cover so we do things like
statistical methods and algorithms but
instead of those being kind of just
general stats or computer science
courses they're completely focused on
the translational and clinical domain so
you're learning about them in terms of
the type of data that we're analyzing
actively right now so very very applied
we also have a course which is on
large-scale data management we used to
do kind of a standard database course
turns out the vast amounts of data that
we're handling far exceed what you can
do with kind of traditional data
management approaches and so we really
focus on that as well and then there's
also the you know continued research
rotations you have a kind of mentored
project based research methods component
and the main that it's split between
winter and spring but the main component
is in spring and that has taken numerous
forms sometimes it's that you're being
Co mentored by faculty who are either
clinicians or basic scientists with one
of our faculty other times it's
you working on a key problem nationally
and so we've been in a number of these
national competitions which are focused
on various kind of key problems in
medicine and translational research and
actually our team have actually done
quite well on that and in those
competitions you're actually pairing
with a key organization or set of
collaborative so all of this is around
collaborative research and then
obviously the potential to plan for
summer internships I should mention that
in the subsequent years in the second
year you're still doing courses it's
really focused at that point on a lot of
the electives that you might want to be
doing in terms of this so machine
learning is a requirement in our program
a lot of students take an advanced
machine learning and other kind of
specializations deep learning etc in
their second year because that's an area
that they really feel they need strength
in you could obviously do extensions
around data management statistical
methods so that is while there's a lot
of core courses we really try to
customize it to what you're trying to
achieve and I think that's key for
anywhere that you go or any type of
studying that you do you shouldn't be
completely locked down so if someone
comes in with a computer science
background they're not going to be doing
a lot of the computational courses
necessarily but they may have a deficit
in terms of some of the biological or
medical domain or in terms of statistics
et cetera and so we do try to tailor
that and the electives very much or
tailored to the type of research that
you're interested in doing at the type
of areas that you're really drawn to the
job prospects in this field are varied
and you'll notice they go across a large
number of different sectors between all
sectors and we had some great examples
of these I will mention as well which is
kind of in-between hybrid we do have
these ideas of these nonprofit entities
and we actually have a close
relationships with a number of them that
are kind of in between academia and
private so things like the Institute for
systems biology or the Allen Brain
Institute so these are regional up in
Seattle so very close they've hosted a
number of our students for internships
or actually hired them and these are the
type of partners where if you're
thinking about something a little bit
non-traditional in terms of that kind of
think-tank or nonprofit institution
rather than definitely going into
industry or
etc that's an option too and then
depending on the degree there's a
variety of different options that you
have I would make the comment that it
really depends on you we have a number
of people here at OHSU who had masters
level training and are basically leading
initiatives and projects so a lot of it
is going to be based on the skill set
and kind of get the training that that
individual has done we also as I
mentioned have had a lot of hybrids so
we've trained lawyers we planed genetic
counselors we have people with very
different backgrounds coming in who want
this training and maybe want to add it
to their career or are looking to have a
different career um so salaries will
vary these are all low estimates because
they came from an earlier survey that
class tour had done but just to give you
an idea of the range we have had an
issue I think many places have had where
we will often have people recruiting our
students before they finish we have a
really great partnership as I mentioned
with Kaiser but they often are looking
at our students as possible recruits so
that's great from a job perspective as
well but especially for the skills that
we mentioned as we talked about a lot of
these are core skills that could be
applied almost anywhere so I think
what's really important if you're coming
to a university hospital it's because
you're really interested in using these
quantitative skills thinking about it in
terms of health care medicine or
translational research that would be the
reason to come to institution like this
because you can do machine learning or
analytics anywhere and what we really
have to offer is that application of
really thinking about it in terms of
trying to change and transform human
health and the treatment of disease also
I should mention there's a spectrum
there it's not all just focused on the
disease component there is a tremendous
amount of work on patient outreach and
engagement and Prevention as well at the
cancer center which I already mentioned
to you before it the night cancers -
there's an entire major Center which is
focused on early detection which is seer
so we have this whole kind of spectrum
of basically you know thinking about the
lifespan how can we prevent these
diseases and if you unfortunately do
have one of them how can we best care
for you that continues on also into
things like survivorship as well so I
just want to finish with some examples
of career advice that we often like to
talk about
in terms of you know I'm often asked
about what the best advice I can give
people I have people contacting me from
all over I'm not gonna read them to you
but I am gonna mention this last one so
there was a really fantastic study done
originally in the economic sector and
then later in the social sciences called
good to greatness his number of years
ago and one of the things that they
looked at was what makes an originally a
business very successful and you kind of
had this Venn diagram of things in the
sweetspot was in the middle and the way
that they phrased it is what are you
good at or what's the company good at
what are you passionate about and what
is sustainable so any of these skills
that we just talked about are highly
sustainable in terms of your job
prospects right that's that's there the
key questions for you is is this
something that's playing To Your
Strengths and this is again most of this
work as we talked about unless you're a
clinician or someone who's getting this
training to augment or a lawyer to
augment your career if you really think
about this as being your career then you
are looking at stuff that is definitely
more detail-oriented more quantitative
in our area so are those your strengths
and if the answers to those are yet then
the last question is is this something
that makes you want to get up in the
morning into it and that's kind of the
internal barometer pieces all of those
things are there I think you've found
your sweet pot spot and the nice thing
is the fact that the sustainable one
because a lot of times people have their
passion of what they want to do and
they're good at but it's very hard for
them to make a living with it in this
case there's such a huge demand for this
such a huge need for this skill set that
is one of the things that is kind of
guaranteed the key is that the other two
pieces for you personally are in place
there's a number of ways that you can
get involved I'm just showing you some
of the social media and the website all
of his seminars today the recording this
for a webinar but all of the seminars
are recorded and are on YouTube so you
can watch any of them and if you're
local or in the case of our interns
you'll be here this summer we have
seminars that are held on Thursday we
often have special seminars in which
we're hosting people and that's a great
way to find out not just about our
faculty here and we'll have a number of
faculty giving kind of overview talks
this summer but also will have invited
collaborators and guests coming in to
talk about a lot of Keith
so with that I'm happy here in the room
to take any questions how does one get
access to their information yeah that
sister formation you want to use
yourself because frankly right so so a
great question there's a couple of ways
to unpack that so because we didn't like
you I'll just repeat the question
because it's recorded the question was
as a and you gave your personal story
here but as a as a patient former
patient how do you get access to your
information especially for think about
your long term care in terms of disease
relapse um so you you said multiple
things that I want to unpack them so the
clinical trial that data by law is
required that that is actually released
and shared and so there is clinical
trials.gov which is we're not just and
very importantly for a clinical trial I
know you're think about it individually
it's not just you but it's very
importantly the trial overall what you
want to know is what did we find we do
have and we talked about the side you
have end of one clinical trials but very
importantly you want to know what was
the overall success of this what was the
real last things like that whatever the
outcomes were so that's one way to find
that out and you should hopefully have
that information you could always
contact MD Anderson but you can look up
on CTV of you know the site etc and if
you know the approximate timing this was
a federal regulation that came aboard
later than we would have liked so
depending on the timing of the trial it
may or may not be there but it is the
requirement now that all clinical trials
are actually captured in that way and
shared even if their results are
negative which is very important because
before we only had them publishing
results that were in publications
excetera and we really need to know
what's happening in the
trial so we have a landscape idea in
terms of your clinical data for your
actual care so I'm assuming if you were
at MD Anderson for a clinical trial you
also were receiving treatment through MD
Anderson correct yes so that is where we
and I mentioned this term right of
access which is under HIPAA and this
isn't this idea that you as a patient
have the right to your data and there
are very few restrictions on that now
the key is what format you get it back
in and that's what we're working on
nationally is to try and improve that
the challenge also is that you have to
unfortunately go to each unless they're
part of a network so unless the Oklahoma
site was part of MD Anderson's network
you probably would have to go to the
multiple different care providers or
hospitals that you were seen at to get
your data but you absolutely have the
right sometimes that will be online some
centers have an app where you can do it
through a patient portal other times you
have to actually send in a written or
faxed request it varies and that's
another thing we're trying to improve
especially at the Cancer Center level we
think about this a lot about how do we
make this better and how can we
standardize this for our patients across
the center's so that's that's another
component and then there's other aspects
which only you have which we would call
you know patient reported things that
might not be collected but would
actually be important if you thinking
about yourself completely if you were
involved in any clinical sequencing the
consent would actually determine what
was released back to you this is a great
kind of segue
when we do sequencing it's related to a
clinical trial as a research study so
the data is not the same like I
mentioned to you we have our targeted
panels that we use in care those are
what we call CLIA assays they can be put
into the electronic health record and
they're used for clinical decision
making all the time a research study may
not be in clinical trials almost always
CLIA but it depends on if you had data
that so I mentioned the BA ml study much
of our data is done just for research
and so it's not all CLIA so we do have
the CLIA targeted panels but we also
have the other data so your consent
would actually dictate if you get that
data back so when you signed it and part
of that is also to protect you
because if the data wasn't done in a
CLIA lab we wouldn't want you or anyone
else analyzing it because we don't have
that same level of confidence in the
data for example it was the sequencing
as deep as Clea Clea labs are incredibly
deep you know what was the protocol and
was it standardized those are the things
that we worry about so that would be
something up front there's been a ton of
engagement with patients on the fact
that when you go to a hospital
you can actually negotiate what happens
to your biospecimens a lot of people
don't know this you can negotiate and
your consent about what's gonna happen
there should be a genetic counselor if
you're doing genetic testing as part of
a study there's always one in clinical
care but in a research study and there's
actually huge discussions around what
data we can give back and part of this
is of course because we don't want to
give you the wrong information and if it
was not done in these standardized you
know clinical labs there's real concern
about that now there are great examples
and I'm blanking on his name at the
moment but I can give it to Lauren to
post and if you google sequenced me this
is a individual who is actually one of
our this is why it's so embarrassing I
can't remember his name but very active
and been very engaged at Intel and he's
a wonderful story of where he actually
had and we have a collaboration with
Intel around precision medicine he
actually had his sequencing done and has
been analyzing the data himself and he's
very active in the community about
patient engagement patients he's also in
that camp of really try and do anything
that he can to augment this is very
common in the rare disease community too
we have amazing stories here so we are
trying to change that model so that the
patient is much more driving this but we
still have many reasons that we have to
be careful because if we ever give you
the wrong information then this could
actually undermine the entire all these
programs so that's that that's the wait
and so there is this weird the rare
disease one we often think about a non
amenity so in many studies if you have
more than if you have less than five
people who have a disease we end up
collapsing it together so you don't
actually get individual patient level
information because you could actually
identify the patient the rare disease
community kind of blew that open and was
like no no we want to be able to share
all of this so if the patients or in
this case if their children their
parents are willing to do this and are
willing to be part of a consortium where
data that we normally wouldn't this this
is the issue the patients have to be
educated and they have to be consenting
knowing what they're consenting to this
is all cultural
the risks we actually believe are very
small you know I'm saying in terms of
someone got your information they often
will throw out the case of an insurance
company the one that might have some
cachet would be a politician obviously
if there's someone that can be
blackmailed because of their data but we
actually believe the risks are very
small but we still have a you know many
responsibilities to the patient to make
sure that it is correct to make sure
that's secure to make sure that you know
that the consent is in place but we do
want to have a dialogue around that
relationship in terms of the consent and
I apologize I can't remember his name
but if you look him up it should come
right away and if not I can send it to
Lauren
any other questions okay if not or come
later for the interns I'm here all
summer and then obviously anyone on the
webinar you can email questions to
Lauren all right thank you